[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وانتظر في كنيسه ويستمنستر على قدوم ساعات
تفصل الملك تشارلز الثالث عن مراسم تتويجه
ليصبح الملك رقم 40
[موسيقى]
تحضيرات جمه يشهدها البلاط الملكي يخيطون
ارضيه الحفل بعنايه فائقه ويدقون المسامير
الاخيره ها هو كرسي التتويج التاريخي يزف
نفسه بعد ورشه ترميم شاقه
هي اقدم قطعه اثاث باقيه ما تزال تستخدم
لغرضها الاصلي لذا فهي نادره للغايه مقعد
يتجاوز عمره 700 سنه طوله متران يعود الى
العصور الوسطى ومصنوع من شجر السنديان
كسته اوراق الذهب منذ امر ادوارد الاول
بصنعه ويعد اقدم قطعه اثاث باقيه من عهده
انه مزين بالنقوش المستخدمه لانشاء الصور
هناك طيور وقديسون وملوك والكثير من اوراق
شجر ايضا ولان القليل جدا من الفن
الانجليزي الذي بقي على قيد الحياه من ذلك
الوقت فانه حقا مثال رائع على جوده
الصناعه اليدويه
ما هذا الكرسي الذي توج عليه 26 ملكا ليضع
عليه حجر سكون اسكتلندي العريق الذي يعرف
ايضا بحجر القدر ومن اجل هذه المراسم طبعا
سينقل الى لندن وسيتوسط الكرسي والحجر
الساحه الفسيفسائيه او كما عرفت لديهم
بالرصيف الكوزمتي اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات